[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to channel
Awesome's orbit report your source for
everything happening around the world in
pop culture and entertainment news i'm
heather ruse and i'm i an away and this
is your news for Monday December 18th
first up we had to talk about the new
Titans news again reminder this is the
live action
Titans that's going to be on the Disney
or DC streaming service not any animated
type Teen Titans go or anything I know
we've had some confusions in the past
but reminder the same Titans we've been
talking about since the beginning of
orbit reporters like I'm saying that one
that one that one we're still talking we
get another first look at a couple more
characters we got to see Hawk and Dove
which are looking super cool the
costumes again we really only get like a
waist up like hips up type of shot from
them but we get to see them paired
together we get kind of like the back
look of hawk so we get to see some of
those wings yeah the wings action which
I'm assuming are gonna be able to come
out and I would have soon enough since
it's not really like a cape like that
like a Batman cape type of right it
seems like he's got a structure to it
right exactly uh I'm assuming hers are
the same that we really only got like
the front inside view of her she's kind
of got like a capelet thing going on
over and underneath them which i think
is a cool detail so that might add some
like more texture and more like visual
like like interest when like the wings
are spread again don't can't see her
wing so we don't know but I like the
little like capelet of like just tiny
little feathers on her shoulder which is
like really cool yeah uh the suit
textures themselves are really
interesting yes I know you were talking
yeah I think it was a good balance
between the like pleather of the CW
and the spandex and bright colors of a
stereotypical superhero costume so you
like the direction and in general that
the costumes are going in looks pretty
good it's got that texture like prints
on it as well similar to like The Hunger
Games uniforms that they had which I
actually am a really big fan of it just
adds some visual interest instead of
just black color adds a little bit more
shape to it even the stitching on her
arm is really cool that we got to see
for a little bit and that helmet that
he's wearing has some really cool
details on it as well there's just
dressing on like his leatherette pieces
on his suit but like mostly that's
helmet it looks like he got hit a couple
times yeah didn't get a new helmet or
maybe just something cool just dressed
[Music]
and her face mask we do not like as much
as the helmet it don't I
I would say that's the only part that I
like kind of fell flat for me on that it
looks like a moth landed on her face or
novelty sunglasses oh yeah absolutely
if like you were having a like Arthur
from the tip novelty sunglasses that's
what they would look like yeah it looks
very muffled though don't I'm not a huge
fan a lot of like look at this strip
across my face you can't tell who I am
type of look so that might I might be
biased on that but just the design in
general is very yeah novelty sunglasses
you know I would say is the closest
thing but it's really cool to be seeing
some new things from Titan I'm really
looking forward to seeing how beast yes
that's gonna be leavin what they do with
Starfire no we're gonna go like more
animated series right or a new 52 right
it's like there's some like more
revealing cut options but I don't think
they're gonna go that way on it no way
yeah I don't think they will I hope they
do but I also don't think they will just
because there's some cool options that
they can go to make it look a little
more like suit suit II you know I mean
yeah
so we don't need mid-drift you know
necessary um earlier this week we got
first a poster at way earlier this week
for ready player
and there was I thought it was faithful
the first time I saw I was like a real
money thing ya know I got approved
thanks Internet though because there are
some top-notch means coming out of that
so thanks a lot internet for just
embracing it and taking that as your own
love cuz it was it was not good not good
and then they also had a second trailer
released for ready player one as well
which I kind of liked better than the
first one because it gave us a lot more
of a detailed storyline right because I
think people who hadn't read the book
saw the first trailer I know you were in
this boat you saw the first trailer we
were like okay what is this about so
this time we actually got to see a
little bit of the story about the Easter
Egg and what the main plot of the story
is um one of the things I did like about
it too is we got a little bit more view
of the real world yeah so we saw more of
Columbus which is where Wade is from um
and it looks I think that looks pretty
good if you read the book you know that
it's supposed to look kind of more
downtrodden and it's a world that people
don't want to live in and that's why the
Oasis is such a huge thing there anyway
you need that juxtaposition right you're
like okay we get it you play video games
we are 100 you need to escape right
because it's so awful because there is
such a huge division mhm
there and I I said this what the first
trailer but I really do love the way
that they make the Oasis look because
instead of going for that like it just
looks like people but we're inside worse
things right they actually look like
avatars yep someone who would go online
and if it's a avatar that you create
wouldn't make it look almost exactly
yourself unless you're like creating a
me I guess but yeah right but you know
if you had free range you would give
yourself awesome anime hair and like
really cool interesting cyberpunk glows
you have to do that you would do that
yeah or even change your gender or
something like that why not you know
so I like the way that they address that
I'm still not 100% sure I'm gonna love
the movie I enjoyed the book I liked the
book I don't think it was the greatest
thing ever it's a fun read so I think
this movie is just gonna be a fun
adventure it'll be a fun movie a lot of
nostalgia I thought it was really
interesting that they added some more
current pop culture and you know we saw
tracer in there yeah Harley and Harley
was my favorite reference though was
that we fight loose all day they're
gonna get the gun note yeah I just I'm
gonna dance for a little bit ideally
thought of you when I saw the gun and it
was my front and center oh yeah just it
popped up and I'm like we got it was so
excited yeah yeah yeah calm down for a
second this week we got a couple of
announcements and one of the first
things that I am very excited about is
Shira is getting a new animated series
on Netflix and I am pretty excited about
this because they're doing it with
DreamWorks and DreamWorks Netflix shows
have been pretty good so far
you know they redid Voltron which Lucas
and I enjoy very much I mean it's
nothing groundbreaking but it's fun it's
funny and as fans of the old Voltron we
really enjoy it so I really think this
has potential to be awesome
absolutely so I'm very excited for this
and I can't wait to see who they cast
and where it's gonna go from there and
what the style of the animation is gonna
be as well but perhaps the bigger
announcement this week is that Disney
has bought sections of box and it's so
official they've been playing this game
a little bit I guess where it's like on
an often under than off but it is
official it has happened they have
bought all of the 21st century film
licenses which means that the x-men and
Fantastic Four are are coming home
they're gonna be a part of the Marvel
Universe which is cool could mean so
many things so many things it's a cool
thing yeah but I'm also not sure that
it's gonna be great for the superhero
film genre because things like Deadpool
and Logan came out of Fox's need to just
do something different that wasn't
Disney right and those films were crates
I love Deadpool I loved Logan and it's
gonna be interesting to see if then that
means that all of the new x-men movies
from here on out are going to be more of
the Marvel Disney formula or if they're
gonna still try to do something
different unique but maybe we'll get a
good fantastic fourth maybe maybe you
can hope right they also bought FX which
is obviously a branch that they that
Disney really is doesn't have much of a
there's some edge ETS yeah yeah yeah I'm
the big fan of American Horror Story so
I'll be interested to see what in the
world happens with that now that it's FX
is Disney's they bought National
Geographic which could be good I mean
Planet Earth a solid and awesome but one
of the more interesting things that they
now have a controlling interest in Hulu
yeah so are they going to like slowly
kill who I mean they're having we're
into the did me dreaming service I don't
I don't know what's gonna happen with
that there's just so much that this
could possibly mean and we are just
going to have to write it out and see
but bit of a mixed bag yeah I'm
personally not too excited about it to
see what happens
dizzy man take so much it's too much
join us I'm just kidding no we're not I
wish we're also going to be doing our
thoughts on Star Wars over on Facebook
at awesome comics so we'll give you a
little bit more spoiler stuff they're
non spoilery though what did you think
of them I loved it I know some people
hate it and that's fine you are totally
entitled to your opinion that's fine but
I really liked it a lot I thought it
felt familiar yeah yet totally new
there's just enough Echo's men so the
Empire Strikes Back that it still felt
familiar but there are some just
completely new things that oh yeah I did
not see coming and I knew to expect plot
twists but it was still like wow wow wow
it was good I really enjoyed it I
thought the characters are well
developed I would say for sure see it in
theaters yes it is absolute it some of
the shots that they set up in the third
act are just great so well worth it to
see it in theaters agreed some of the
world-building is really great we get to
see some new creatures and
alien races and it's at which I love
specially boards I was a fan of the
board but I also liked it and I also
agree that you should see it in theaters
to make your own opinion it's it's well
worth the watch if if only once if it
you're not as thick of a fan it's still
worth seeing in the theaters to get some
get some Carrie Fisher that's gonna be
it from us hear how they're broken
people find you on social media you can
find me on Twitter at Heather ruse
Instagram at a truce or twitch twitch TV
slash Heather ruse and as always you can
find me on Facebook as I gonna wait
everywhere else as awesome Ayanna and
again be sure to go to Facebook at
awesome comics to see our review of star
wars but it is spoilers so see it first
yeah you do you otherwise that's gonna
be it from us here let us know in the
comments down below what you thought us
are worth and make sure to put some
spoiler warnings if you do go into
spoilers otherwise let us know what we
missed this week and we will catch you
next week for a special episode of a
little bit reports get Heights in the
meantime hey can you beam us up
[Applause]
you